thanks everybody I'm Debbie it's so
great to be here and I'm gonna start
when I talk with a little logo we all
know well my story begins when I was in
your shoes I was a Stanford student and
for me getting into Stanford was
probably one of the biggest things that
had ever happened to me I grew up in a
really small town in Rhode Island I went
to a pretty average public school and
when I found out I got into Stanford
they announce it on the loudspeaker and
everyone in the cafeteria got up and
cheered like it was that big of a deal
and so as I was preparing to go off to
college I remember one day my math
teacher pulled me aside and asked me
what I planned on majoring in and at the
time I was a high school senior I had no
idea she so I think that you should
consider engineering and I remember that
moment she said that I've told this
story a million times what is so funny
because in my head I pictured an old man
driving a train I had no idea what
engineering was but whatever picture I
had in my head was the least appealing
interesting thing to me at all and you
know I kind of thought she was crazy but
sure enough I I got to Stanford and my
freshman year I had no idea what I
wanted to study and so I thought why not
try engineering so I signed up for
Emme 101 I walked into the room and
almost just turned right out and walked
out the other way because I looked
around and I saw barely any girls and I
thought you know I'm not sure if this is
really for me but luckily I stayed in
the class and I'm really glad that I did
because it was the first time that I
learned what engineering was and we
weren't fixing train engines in that
class it was an amazing class because it
was really an introduction to just the
way the world works we learned the
simple machines we learned how to build
stuff how to invent how to be problem
solvers
it was incredibly creative and inspiring
to me to think that I could be an
inventor and solve big problems in the
world that was something I was really
passionate about and so I decided I'm
gonna study engineering from that moment
on was the first time in my life I ever
got a see the first time in my life I
ever struggled and hoped that I would
just pass class
it was the first time in my life that I
really actually challenged myself and
oftentimes in those classes I was the
only girl in group projects with all
guys and it often felt like they look at
me and think ah we got stuck with the
girl and I started to feel that way
about myself too I often felt it wasn't
good enough it wasn't smart enough I
almost dropped out of the major a
million times I I wasn't set up for
success from my public school not even
knowing what engineering was and looking
around and seeing guys in my classes who
had already learned how to program
calculators and already knew how to
build a million things but luckily I
stuck with it I stayed in it I studied
hard put in the midnight oil and I ended
up graduating and that day that I
graduated in 2005 was actually the year
that Steve Jobs gave the commencement
speech so I was there and it was the
proudest day of my life because I had
done something hard you know I had
really tried something hard and I had
ended up achieving it and so that
feeling that you get when you actually
really apply yourself and you climb that
mountain and you get to the top you feel
invincible
that was how I felt and that was kind of
the gift that Engineering gave to me was
proving that I could that was an
unbelievable feeling and so years later
I had been searching ever since that day
I graduated to find my passion you know
like what was that thing that Steve Jobs
said go out and find your passion I
wanted to find that for myself but I
didn't know what it was and so I spent
about seven years at different jobs and
finally I found it and it happened one
day I had got together with a group of
friends and we started this tradition
called idea brunch where we'd get
together and each person would get up in
front of the group and share their
latest harebrained idea for an app or a
company or whatever just like one of
those things that you kind of news about
when you're driving in the car
of course over breakfast and in that
session one day my friend Christie who
studied engineering with me here at
Stanford got up she started complaining
about how few women there were in our
engineering classes and she said you
know as a little girl
I got interested in engineering because
I grew up playing with my older brothers
hand-me-down construction toys like
Legos and erector sets and Lincoln Logs
and that's what got me interested in
engineering and I kind of in that moment
thought back to my childhood growing up
with me and my little sister we never
played with any toys like that at all
because those were boys toys and I
remember in my engineering classes a lot
of the assignments that we did we built
out of construction toys and I realized
that if I had grown up with this stuff I
might have I might have thought of
myself as an engineer far younger then
you know by the time I was 18 years old
and so it sounds really corny but the
moment she had this idea at idea branch
of engineering toys for girls was the
moment where it was like the fireworks
went off the Lightning bulb like I just
knew oh my god this is what I was born
to do he knew it instinctively in that
moment and so the very next day I
decided I'm gonna go to the toy store
and get a lay of the land here I'm sure
times have changed since Kristy and I
were kids I'm sure there's got to be a
lot of toys for girls that encourage
engineering thinking so I I went to the
toy store and this is what I found I
couldn't believe it
the pink aisle so this was like the most
disgusting like dolls that look like
street corner girls it was fairies
princesses tea sets ironing boards I
mean it was all about domestic it's all
about the way that you look meanwhile in
the blue aisle was all of the smart math
and science games heroes action figures
and it just felt like this isn't there
so the thing about the blue Isle was
that it had a lot of toys that helped
develop spatial skills now this is
something as I started to do research
into you know how would I advantage
girls how would I give them a leg up
give them something that might prepare
them for engineering spatial skills kept
coming up is underdeveloped in girls
well interestingly I also read that
spatial skills are commonly found in
case
who grew up playing with construction
toys kids who play with construction
toys have better spatial skills boys
have better spatial skills because they
played with construction toys so I
thought okay if I want to help develop
girls spatial skills maybe if I could
get them building with construction toys
then you know that might be away but
other construction toys had tried this
before the genius approach was let's
make them pink and then girls will play
with them well I noticed in the toy
store that these pink construction toys
were sitting in the corner of the aisle
with dust all over them and I thought
maybe there's a better way and so as I
started to research I spent weeks and
weeks observing reading every book I
could on child development begging my
friends to let me babysit their kids and
I observed something I found that if I
if I just gave a girl a bunch of
construction toys a lot of times you
know she would you know play for a
little bit and get disinterested in in
one of my sessions I actually asked a
bunch of girls well what do you want to
play with and a bunch of them said well
we actually want to read a story we love
this new book that we got and they ran
upstairs and brought a book down and I
remember in that moment thinking huh we
have all these construction toys on the
floor and then we're sitting here
reading this book together and I noticed
that girls really love stories and
narrative and characters and so I had
this kind of genius idea which was girls
love stories why don't I incorporate
storytelling with building because you
know a lot of boys tend to take
construction toys and build a big Tower
and then smash it against the wall but
it girls really like kind of building
when there was more of a reason why sort
of the narrative in a context so that's
my my big idea was combining
storytelling with building so I so this
is kind of funny my grandmother is
actually a pioneer she's one of the
first female animators and created mr.
Magoo and so I've always had this like
love of cartooning and art and so my
very first prototype of Goldie Blox
wasn't a construction toy at all I
actually drew a sketch of a little girl
who was not a princess but not a nerd
she was gonna be a builder and in these
sketches I had Goldie building these
elaborate cool machines and so I I
started prototyping kind of what would
Goldie build what would be some of the
machines that she would make and in this
first prototype I created a belt drive
where Goldie built a machine to help her
dog chases tail so this is all stuff
like I'm going to the hardware store I'm
like rummaging through my drawers with
thread spools and clay and there's very
these ramshackled prototypes but it was
enough to kind of get my idea out of you
know a girl character in the in a an
associated building set where kids could
kind of build along with Goldie and once
I had this prototype I was just like oh
my god this is genius
right like this nobody has done this
this is genius and so I came up with
this plan right like this is my grand
master plan we've got this original
prototype that I know is just this
breakthrough idea and one day I'm gonna
disrupt the pink aisle in every toy
store with this idea so there wasn't
very straightforward path to that is I
had thought but in my talk today what I
want to share with you all is sort of
this sort of circuitous path that I took
from having my kind of first prototype
in hand to actually getting Goldie Blox
onto the shelves of toy stores around
the world so I'm gonna start with my
first step in kind of my my first sort
of lesson learned along the way which is
you know at the very beginning having
this first prototype I had to learn the
difference between being an inventor and
being an entrepreneur so I brought my
first prototype to the New York Toy Fair
to get advice from the bigwigs in the
toy industry and very early on and in my
mind I'm like this is the best idea ever
everybody's gonna love this this is what
I heard it was mainly old white men
ensue
to run the toy industry who said you
can't fight nature they said girls want
to play in the pink aisle girls don't
want to build this idea is never gonna
go mainstream so at this point I had
quit my job and I was going off with my
life savings so this was not very good
news to hear
I was pretty dejected as you can imagine
and right after the Toy Fair I had
actually signed up to go to this social
entrepreneurship conference and to be
honest I wasn't in the mood to go at all
I kind of just wanted to go home and
crawl up in a ball and hide but you know
it already signed up and it paid so I go
to the conference and it was this
conference for social entrepreneurs
there were about a hundred people there
and the deal was everybody who was there
had to get up and share their idea in
front of the room well I wasn't feeling
so great about my idea at that moment
because all of those old toy men had
told me it was a stupid idea
but I got up anyway
to share the idea and unlike the
reception at the Toy Fair all of the
young people at the social
entrepreneurship conference they were
inspired they all got up to their feet
and cheered they formed a line around
the building all wanting to be a part of
it and there was something that I
learned that was really helpful at that
conference and it was this concept of
being an inventor being an entrepreneur
I learned that being an inventor means
that you sort of hold up alone kind of
working on your idea trying to come up
with something and that's what I've been
doing for the last few months I've been
kind of alone in my apartment making
those sketches and prototypes and even
though it was my passion it was what I
knew I wanted to do with my life
I was lonely yeah I wasn't having a lot
of fun and I was too afraid to talk to
people about my idea because I was
afraid that some big toy company might
steal it and so I was just I was lonely
the moment I went to this social
entrepreneurship conference and I built
up the courage to get up and share my
idea without making somebody sign an NDA
which by the way it even made my mom
sign one I was so paranoid the moment I
actually eyes I'm not even kidding I
have it a copy of it the moment I
actually finally kind of put myself out
there like everything changed
all of a sudden I wasn't feeling lonely
anymore I had people coming to my
apartment every day evenings weekends we
were working on the prototypes together
they were helping me they were giving me
advice they were giving me ideas just
volunteering because they were
passionate about it they helped me kind
of take that first sort of ugly
prototype and they helped me rapidly
prototype it again and again and again
they helped me test it with kids we
tested it with over a hundred kids and
each time we observed kids playing with
it we found ways to make it better and
better and so all of a sudden I went
from being this kind of lone hermit
inventor to being an entrepreneur
because the entrepreneur is somebody who
shares their vision and more importantly
brings people along and the moment that
those people lined up to be a part of it
and I let them is the moment that I
became an entrepreneur and so with their
help I went from this you know lonely
hermit prototype in my living room to a
final toy that girls loved like girls in
like tutus and Tiaras we're building
belt drives and loving it and so I knew
I had it but the problem was I knew that
all of those old people in the toy
industry were never gonna believe me
they all thought that this was never
gonna sell and so I put it up on
Kickstarter and before I knew it I had
sold about a million dollars of
goldieblox
in pre-orders before manufacturing a
single unit and so the amazing thing was
that this this mission that I believed
in by being able to sort of share my
vision in a video format was kind of the
same way that I shared my vision at that
conference where I just kind of talked
to people about hey here's
I'm doing and here's why and you know I
was authentic and I invited people to
help by taking this Kickstarter backing
it and making it a reality and the
concept went viral
all of a sudden TechCrunch wrote it up
the Atlantic Huffington Post was all
over the news of you know can an
engineering toy get girls interested can
an engineering toy solve the gender gap
and my team of three full-time employees
this is our packing party where we
started shipping out kickstarter orders
and these are some of our very first
backers and so you know very quickly in
my very first year went from being an
inventor to an entrepreneur and was very
proud to go back to that Toy Fair with
my own booth one year later and sure
enough who came over to the booth but
Toys R Us and they said hey you're
making us look bad we'd like to carry
your product and so before I knew it
six months later Goldie Blox was on the
shelves of choice RS nationwide which I
thank you
so which led us to year two and the next
kind of big lesson learned for me which
is how very limited resources can
actually be a big strategic advantage so
getting into Toys R Us nationwide was
this enormous accomplishment I remember
walking in the store for the first time
and seeing the toy on the shelf and I
had tears both of joy tears of joy that
I had accomplished the impossible and
also tears of dread because I just
realized oh my gosh this toy is one tiny
box in a sea of pink and like how are we
gonna compete how are we gonna compete
and what actually started to happen was
we started to get our sales results in
from Toys R Us and the toys weren't
really selling and so you know we had
disrupted the pink aisle but we were
gonna get kicked out of there any moment
unless the sales started to pick up and
so I asked Toys R Us well what do we do
how do we you know what can we do give
us some ideas we'll do anything we want
to get the toys to start selling and
they said well usually our partners do
national TV commercials and that usually
helps get the toys to sell so those cost
about two million dollars that was
really not in the cards and so we had to
get scrappy so we invited our
Kickstarter backers to join us in sorry
I'm missing this slide we invited our
Kickstarter backers to the Toys R Us
parking lot and we said hey we're gonna
film a video together and our idea was
if we want to tell the world that we're
in Toys R Us let's film a shot of a
bunch of girls running through the pink
aisle screaming so we invite our
Kickstarter backers to the parking lot
about 50 people showed up kids and their
parents we're getting ready to kind of
get this stealth shot and then the
security guards start circling I'm like
oh my god we're gonna like get arrested
the so the manager of Toys R Us comes
out with his clipboard and they say with
what's going on here and so I told a
little white lie said we
we're the lovely girls club on a field
trip to the girl's favorite place in the
world Toys R Us and he said oh my gosh
why didn't you call me I hope we have
enough gift bags he runs in comes back
out with Jeffrey the giraffe like
handing gift bags out to the girls
announcing us and welcoming us in we set
up her video equipment get the shot
posted the video on YouTube and we got
about a million views and the story
broke that Goldie Blox broke into Toys R
Us and it went viral and all of a sudden
sales started to pick up and so we kept
trying to figure out ways like how do we
even though we're this teeny tiny team
were only five people like how do we get
the word out and we found out about a
contest being run by Intuit where one
small business had the chance to win a
free Superbowl commercial so I'm like
okay there's our national TV advertising
we got to win this and so again it
sounds crazy like how could we win a
Super Bowl commercial but we just put it
on the wall and we said this is our goal
and our team of five people every single
day tried to get creative and how are we
gonna win this
and so we emailed our Kickstarter
backers we emailed our fans just begged
every day vote for us vote for us vote
for us and sure enough out of 30,000
small businesses who applied goldieblox
was the grand prize winner and so we had
a commercial in the Super Bowl which I
will play for you if it will play
[Music]
congratulations Goldie Blox Intuit
QuickBooks is proud to have put your
small business on the big game so at
that point 100 million people had found
out about Goldie Blox and our mission to
disrupt the pink Isle and so all of
those old toy guys who said it was never
gonna go mainstream in that 30 seconds
were entirely proved wrong and from
there just an amazing domino effect
happened where we got the opportunity
need to have a float in the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade I got to meet
President Obama and be inducted as the
presidential ambassador for
entrepreneurship just doors started
flying open left and right for Goldie
Blox and it was this amazing and
exciting time but houston we had a
problem and that was the demand for our
toys was growing so fast so fast that
our team didn't have time to quality
check everything as well as we wanted
and so going into year three Goldie Blox
is on top of the world meanwhile we have
a problem with our blocks which leads us
to kind of the next lesson learned which
is how do you turn failure into an
opportunity so my biggest fear in
starting Goldie Blox was what if the
girl construction toy wasn't well
engineered like what if we gave a
construction toy out and little girls
got frustrated and the opposite effect
happened where instead of getting them
interested and excited in engineering
they got frustrated it was literally my
worst nightmare and I was living it so
in 2014 Super Bowl commercial Toys R Us
nationwide were shipping tens of
thousands of units from something that
had you know less than a year before
been a prototype in my living room
anyone who has a hardware company knows
this is very common you're gonna have
problems but this this was just a whole
level of something I was completely
unprepared for we started getting
complaints in that the blocks were not
fitting right a little bit too loose and
I
just so upset I could barely handle it
so we thought okay what what would we do
what would an engineer do when you have
this big hairy problem let's let's break
it down into simple and manageable steps
right so what do we need to do so first
we need to fix the block hole
okay can we do that great we know how to
fix it now you know we've been able to
manufacture better blocks the problem
was solved but now how do we go back and
tell all of those people like hey
everybody we fixed the problem and you
should trust Goldie Blox again let's try
building again and so yeah I made a
pretty major executive decision and we
were a small start-up at the time
without a lot of resources but I thought
there's no better way to deploy our
resources than going back to all of
those customers telling them that we
fixed our blocks and giving them new
ones and so we did a huge campaign we
reached out to everybody to tell them
about our new blocks filmed a video
myself kind of being vulnerable and
talking about the mistakes that we made
but what we were doing to fix it and we
also actually wrote a letter from Goldie
to each kid which we had personalized
with their name talking about how
engineers don't always get it right the
first time but that doesn't mean that
you give up it means that you keep going
you keep iterating and you make it
better and we actually drew a picture of
the engineering solution that got the
block to fit better and we sent it out
to every kid we actually went and
replaced a million blocks which was an
enormous investment in worth every
single penny so we turned that failure
into an opportunity and every person
that we touched fell in love with our
brand even more so then I got to my next
lesson on my circuitous path which is
designed for the customer not the
retailer so Goldie Blox is flying high
and the reach every retailer wants to
carry it I mean the brand is so hot and
sure enough Walmart calls and Walmart is
begging for Goldie Blox I mean imagine
being in the situation where Walmart
begging for your product and so in order
to sell at Walmart we were told by you
know a lot of the toy industry veterans
that you have to have products at ten at
$9.99 you have to have low price point
products that's what sells at Walmart
and so our whole focus for the year was
okay we're gonna go big Goldie Blox is
gonna hit the mainstream and everybody
drop everything let's figure out how to
make toys that are ten bucks and so and
make a lot of them because we have to
have a lot of products to fill up a lot
of room so we had a really small team
still about 15 people and we are just
bending over backwards under insane
timelines and all we're thinking about
is hitting that $9.99 price point and
hitting the the Shelf date on time what
ended up happening was we worked as hard
and as fast as we could we went from six
products to 18 products in less than a
year getting out as many products as we
could at the cheapest prices that we
could and as a result those cheap
products very quickly went on clearance
we had kind of forgotten the most
important thing which is if Goldie Blox
is going to be successful we have to
design for the girls like we every
product it doesn't matter how much it
costs if it's not a product that excites
and gets every girl interested in
wanting to build more and more we failed
and so by the end of the year we had
gone from sort of being on the top of
the world to sort of hitting this real
reality major major reality check which
leads me to my final lesson which is
never ever give up
so kind of every startup is a roller
coaster you know at one moment you're at
the top of the world and I feel like we
at this moment had sort of gone right
back down to the bottom again and so we
had to sort of have a soul-searching
moment of like where do we go from here
like what do we do now and so
we thought okay if we're let's forget
about designing for the retailer let's
forget about the toy aisle is forget
about disrupting the toy aisle let's
think about making the best possible
product that inspires these girls let's
think about like what have we done so
far that girls really love and let's
lean into that and so as we started to
look at that and think about it more and
more we'd realized that in fact what
girls were really loving about
goldieblox
they were loving building and we were
introducing it to them in in a new way
which was good but what we noticed they
loved the most was they loved the idea
of this character Goldie they were
dressing up as her for Halloween they
were wanting to they were admiring her
and every time we had kind of introduced
Goldie and her friends to them like
these characters and these stories like
that was what was really engaging them
and that was what was really unique
about us like tinker toy doesn't do that
and connects doesn't do that know you
know the construction toys didn't do
that that was something really special
about us it was really the stories and
so we started leaning into that more and
more and really kind of thinking more
and more spending our time not focusing
on what can we make for 9.99
but focusing on how would we create this
role model Goldie to really become a
role model of girls to really become
kind of an inspiring maker it's like who
is she you know like what who are her
parents who her friends quit town -
Sheila Minh what kinds of things does
she build we started writing much richer
and deeper stories and really sort of
figuring out like who who is this girl
and and can we really develop enough
story about this character that she will
be somebody that every girl falls in
love with and wants to be and so we
started leaning into that more and more
and just yesterday we actually announced
chapter books with our partner Random
House and so now
we'll start to get out these really rich
stories about this girl who believe it
or not is literally the first girl
engineer protagonists in children's
entertainment like it took until 2012
for somebody to create a girl engineer
in children's entertainment and so now
we have chapter books coming out about
Goldie we started figuring out how do we
get these stories out more we started
just experimenting on YouTube and making
short videos just as quickly as we could
with stories about Goldie we took our
little toy character and we created a
web video series called toy hackers
where in each episode our little toys
would have to solve engineering problems
and so they would get a prompt and just
using common household objects in each
episode these little toy figurines would
build solutions to problems and every
week we put up a new episode where we
just made them in our office and the
videos started to climb where we would
get views and more views and more views
and our subscribers of kids watching the
content started to go up we started to
think well how else can we get
Goldie this character out in front of
kids in a way that you know we can
control it we can own it and we can do
it scrappy and we took all of our our
toy parts and we put them into
curriculum kits so where we could get it
into the classroom and have kind of stem
educational curriculum for kindergarten
through third grade and you know it it
sounded really daunting like how would
we now create like go into the entire
education market well we all we did was
call up our friend who was an elementary
school teacher and ask her if she would
help and she literally did it in
exchange for free toys and she called up
her other friends and before we knew it
we had all of these teachers
passionately wanting to create Goldie
box curriculum for students and coming
by the office everyday and putting stuff
together going out into classrooms
testing it with kids and showing how we
could have this character Goldy kind of
walk kids through stem curriculum in a
way that wasn't intimidating for the
kids or the teachers and so we started
launching these classroom kits we
started putting out apps and we started
developing a Bible for an animated
series and so really kind of thinking
about if Disney Princess over the last
ten years has built an entire lifestyle
around being a princess with cartoons
and films and apps and books and room
decor and costumes where every little
girl gets to live out princess fantasy
we started to kind of shift our strategy
you think well how could Goldie Blox
enable that that maker culture that
maker lifestyle how do we enable every
little girl to be a maker and how does
Goldie Blox the character and her
friends inspire girls to want to build
and invent not just do their hair put on
makeup and so it's been a very
circuitous path
just to recap kind of the lessons
learned over the years so number one the
concept of being an entrepreneur I think
has been so important again the notion
of just hustling bringing people on
board and I think one thing too to point
out about that that's important is when
you have something like Goldie Blox that
has a social mission that's bigger than
you where if you succeed it's going to
benefit other people it's going to help
change the world it kind of gives you
the Mojo to go out and make kind of
audacious asks and go ask people to get
involved and be a part of it
because it's not in some weird gross
self-promoting kind of way it's in a way
where you know you're you know that
you're doing something bigger than
yourself and I think that's what really
enabled me to sort of act like that
entrepreneur when normally iwon wasn't
the kind of person who enjoyed
networking or that kind of stuff there
was something about the social mission
of it that enabled me to really start
acting like an entrepreneur I'm the
limited resources being a strategic
advantage so anyone who goes into
entrepreneurship will face this I mean
it's the whole point if you're starting
something out you're going to have very
very limited resources and to even think
that goldieblox could one day become as
big as Disney Princess I mean it's it's
incredibly audacious it's it sounds
crazy yet you know to think that Debbie
sterling could graduate from Stanford
with an engineering degree also seemed
pretty preposterous and yet if you kind
of put that goal out there and you work
really hard and you learn that you can
achieve things you know you start to
realize like hey you can you can get
there if you break these things down
into simple and manageable steps and
sometimes having those fewer resources
means you're an underdog you know and
people root for that they want to be a
part of it and sometimes when you don't
have that many resources it forces you
to think outside the box like what a big
toy company ever break into Toys R Us
and almost got arrested no but that's
what makes us so awesome the next lesson
which is turning failure into an
opportunity I think it's so important I
see it every day I see girls being
afraid to fail I see girls little girls
being so obsessed with perfection that
they almost don't want to try something
if they think they're going to be bad at
it that's something that I want to
overcome with Goldie Blox so I want to
let them know that engineering is all
about failing
and failing is great because when you
fail and you learn something from it and
then you succeed later
you know that's there's nothing greater
than that and if you're not comfortable
with failure you're never gonna be able
to succeed as an entrepreneur so you
know rather than being so afraid to fail
you don't even try just you know leaning
into failure and taking every failure as
an opportunity to learn something new
I'm designed for the customer this may
be the biggest lesson I've learned over
all I can't stress enough as you go into
entrepreneurship you start building your
business you'll have investors you'll
have people kind of all pushing for
different things and at the end of the
day if you're not delivering something
if you're not focused a hundred percent
on your customer and in our case
honoring the little girl then you you've
missed the mark and so just always
remembering that who your customer is
and just staying true to that and
defending it and then the last one is
never ever giving up entrepreneurship is
so hard for me I think if I wasn't just
so obsessed with achieving this mission
you know delivering this to girls of
giving every girl around the world kind
of that nudge that my engineering
teacher gave me like that to me it's
just what gets me up every morning and
so I've had so many failures along the
way with Goldie Blox so many moments
where you know quietly I've wanted to
give up so many things that didn't could
work out the way I'd planned and having
to go back into the office every morning
with a big smile having to go and put
myself out there and pitch or be on the
news when I know in the back of my head
things actually aren't really working
out it's that's what every entrepreneur
goes through and the ones who are
successful are the ones who refuse to
give up
so just closing my talk so we're going
to go into Q&A here
but it has been a wild ride toward
disrupting the pink aisle and I think
what I've learned along the way is you
know it was amazing that I achieved that
in such a short amount of time but it
actually isn't wasn't the big goal that
you know that that I really needed to do
and now I'm focused on an even bigger
goal which is you know really building
this character brand to become sort of
the face if you will of the maker
generation so you know for every little
girl who grows up with her princess face
I'm gonna give her her maker face I
don't think that it's going to be a very
straight path I think I suspect that
that arrow will break in a million
different directions but I couldn't
enjoy the ride more
[Applause]
so I think we have about 15 ish minutes
for QA go ahead so I'm a guy I'm an
engineer I have a six-year-old daughter
and so you know I'm doing my best to try
and encourage her in this way baby coos
goldieblox
but I'm wondering what thinking you've
given to those who maybe don't come from
my background you know some of it comes
naturally then my daughter but some of
it also is unnatural I didn't have
sisters things like that so what about
helping mothers and fathers who don't
come from an engineering background the
same as you're doing teachers hmm
yeah so I'm you know I think one of the
reasons why Goldie Blox was kind of this
break out was because we I think we
realized early on that you know most
people aren't advanced engineers and
there are very few women who are
engineers and so if if this product line
was only focused around people who
really deeply understand engineering we
were gonna have a pretty niche market
and so really early on and we continue
to do this more and more was how do we
introduce these engineering concepts in
such a way that is accessible to anybody
so you don't need to have an engineering
degree how do you make it fun how do you
make it so that kids are building and
playing stuff and they don't even know
that they're learning something and so
that was really our goal and I would say
that along the way as we've been
developing more and more products and
kind of seeing how people have reacted
with them if anything I've learned that
really the more fun you make it and the
less you try and kind of make it feel
like you're in school the better and and
I think what we have found that helps is
kind of from the product experience it
needs it needs to be so fun kids don't
even realize they're learning but
offering parents tools parents who are
interested in
getting their kids interested in this
stuff we've been actually offering a lot
in our social media so sharing articles
or tips on how to get your kids
interested like pointing out hey you can
you can teach your kid this you can
teach your kid that so we've really sort
of separated it out so the play
experience the toys have to be fun it's
a toy but we have found ways of sort of
engaging with parents sort of separately
on those platforms the question was it
seems like we didn't what was the
difference between both pre pre
investment and post investment so at the
beginning I'm I was really building the
company off of my life savings so I had
quit my job and I had saved up a certain
amount of money in my bank account and
was like okay I'm gonna this money's
gonna last me a year to really go for
this because I'd been kind of working on
nights and weekends and in my spare time
and I just gotten to the point where I'm
like I can't I'm never gonna get
somewhere if I just only do it in my
spare time I got to go all-in or it's
never gonna happen and so it was scary
to do that so I'm like well what if what
if I fail but then I thought okay well
what's the worst-case scenario here is
that I spend a year of my life savings I
run out of money
I you know it didn't work out and so
I'll just go get a job you know and and
I'll never regret kind of giving it a
real go of something that I was
passionate about even if it doesn't work
out I would never regret that and so at
the beginning kind of going off of my
life savings one of the benefits of that
was that with such few resources I
didn't have the money to spend on
expensive prototypes and as the result I
had to make quick and dirty prototypes
and they weren't as precious to me and
so I'd be willing to just toss toss the
idea because I hadn't spent $5,000 on it
convincing myself that it was a great
idea even though observing kids hating
it
you know and
there was a huge advantage to just going
off my life savings another thing was
that because I didn't have a huge
investment I I decided to do
crowdfunding if I had raised a bunch of
money at the beginning I probably
wouldn't have done crowdfunding I
probably would have gone the traditional
route of selling into brick-and-mortar
stores but by doing crowdfunding it was
actually a very great marketing tool
because it put the idea out and it ended
up going viral and so you know these
were just great things that happened out
of you know me kind of going off you
know at the beginning the life savings
we raised our first major round of
capital right after the Kickstarter had
kind of gone through the roof and there
was a huge change after that I think the
biggest thing is once you start raising
real money it really it enables you to
start actually hiring employees is
probably one of the biggest changes and
so very quickly it went from sort of
feeling like volunteers you're in an
apartment you're like you know - you're
a company you're set up like you have
weekly meetings like you have annual
reviews like it formalizes things pretty
quickly the other thing is once you take
in money then you have investors who
have certain expectations and a lot of
times the investors want to see you make
as much money as quickly as possible
and many times that's actually maybe not
the best thing that you should be doing
and so one thing one last thing I'm kind
of rambling here but I think that I've
learned that took me a real long time to
learn that I know now is it's really
good to you know it's important to find
great investors but it's also important
to find really great strategic advisors
as well who are really deeply
knowledgeable about your space and it's
really important that when you have to
formalize things you know whether it's
quarterly board meetings or whatever to
make sure that the investors who have
money in the company but also the
advisors who know the right things you
should be doing are all in the same room
so that if the investor is saying no
sell sell sell more more more more money
more money more money in neural on the
phone like oh okay okay then on the
phone with the other advisor don't do
that like you should be focusing on this
like oh okay okay
bring them together because as soon as
you start taking money and there's just
a lot of pressures and outside
expectations that you need to answer to
and it's good to kind of get the right
people in the room sort of discussing it
as a group rather than like separately
the question was how do you measure the
impact of goldieblox on girls motor
skills or interest in engineering so
early on I had to decide whether I was
gonna set up goldieblox as a for-profit
or not-for-profit and it was a kind of
tricky thing so I'm like well Goldie
Blox could be a non-profit because
that's doing this great social mission
but at the same time like it's a
consumer product and it could be a
for-profit company and I wasn't sure
which way to go and actually part of the
reason why I chose the for-profit route
was I felt like it would be a faster way
to achieve our goals
the nonprofit route requires you to do a
lot of measurement on things that I sort
of felt like might be difficult to
measure it might take a really long time
to measure and so I'm and I'd works in
the nonprofit world before and I'd seen
those challenges and so right now the
way I measure my except the goldieblox
success is a few things so one I'm it's
a lot of it's anecdotal so every day we
get photos and letters and videos of
kids and their parents writing in
telling us how Goldie Blox has changed
our lives girls kind of calling
themselves engineers so you know parents
today I can't believe that she even
knows what that is those are kinds of
anecdotal ways we're like wow we're
making a difference the other way to
just tell we're making a difference this
how many kids are buying our toys and
coming back and
more because if they're buying them and
playing with them then we know that
we're building and they're learning
something and then the other way is
there have been universities and sort of
third parties who have been interested
in the effects that you're talking about
and so we have given them the green
light to go and conduct research studies
which is really great because then we're
not like conducting our own research
study or and then we can go publish some
article about like the change that we
made where we like stacked the deck and
we just seem better than it was like I
actually am more interested in these
unbiased third party studies one
recently came out that was done by Penn
State over a period of three years and
was fascinating to see what they've
learned and it's going to be published
publicly soon that's a great question
how are we going to sell the product in
poor countries so um it's so growing
internationally is a beast unto itself I
have learned the hard way that focusing
on getting things right sort of first in
the US and like under things that you
can control even when there's a lot of
countries all around the world they're
asking for it it's better to kind of get
things really optimized first in kind of
the US but then keeping in mind your
long term goal of wanting to make it
available to little kids all around the
world our plan for that is actually by
creating an animated series for a Goldie
Blox and her friends and distributing
that globally and finding a partner that
gets that out all around the world will
enable us for more kids to find out
about Goldie Blox all around the world
and once we've done that then that
enables us to find partners who are
going to create Goldie Blox products
they're available to those kids around
the world
and once we've done that we'll be able
to find partners like great foundations
or nonprofits that want to help pay to
make it available to kids who can't
afford it
blonde hair and blue eyes and looks like
certain types of kids are you planning
on sort of making a more diverse set of
characters that might be more relevant
for kids who don't look like that yeah
we actually have you can't I don't know
if you can really see but Goldie's best
friends so Ruby who's african-american
Lee who's Chinese and Farrah is Hispanic
so we actually already have a crew of
diverse characters which is incredibly
important to me
Goldie's sort of our main hero
protagonist so she's like our Harry
Potter if you will but she her friends
are ethnically diverse do you see a
potential problems with having the
minority characters as supporting roles
as opposed to painting protagonist role
you know a lot of kids properties right
now are worried about that and so what
they end up creating for their
franchises are sort of friend ensembles
so if you see like I don't know if
you're familiar with DC superhero girls
they have like eight girls and they have
they all have like the same body type
but they all have like each ethnicity
lego friends the same thing like a group
of six girls of every color monster high
like that all of them do the same thing
they have the group and and I thought
about that and my approach is I'm you
know I really think and what I'm excited
about is really creating kind of more of
an iconic an iconic hero if you will
like a girl who is an engineer and and
there never really was one before most
kind of main girl characters are
princess
and beauty queens or pop stars I wanted
to create an iconic girl maker and when
I first drew the picture of her I called
her Goldie Blox and I didn't really
think anything of it I just gave her
blonde hair because her name was Goldie
Blox you know and I kind of drew a girl
that looked like me because I was almost
sort of making like a little mini Debbie
as a cartoon character I feel I'm
excited in the stories that were telling
about like this girl who's like a Pippi
Longstocking punky brewster unique
eccentric individual who's a maker and
by kind of building her up as an iconic
girl and she will have friends of other
ethnicities but I think that there's a
really strong storytelling in building
an icon the question was around gender
specific marketing or you know colors or
like the Goldie Blox seems like it's
very targeted to girls and what's my
opinion on gender specific marketing in
general and toys so when I was first
kind of choosing the color palette for
Goldie Blox I had a big choice to make
which was I can go pastel pink and
purple which is what's very popular for
girls and is common to the pink aisle I
can go entirely gender neutral which is
like primary red blue and green which
I'm in the construction category is so
commonly boy that I think most people
would just assume that that is for boys
and so instead of going and I wanted to
make sure the girls were gonna play with
it so I didn't want it to be confused
for something that was for boys because
my goal was I want to really give girls
an advantage that they had been missing
out on because they hadn't been marketed
to and so I opted for like
just an entirely different color palette
which was you know just all kinds of
bright and modern colors that include
pink and purple and green and brown and
all kinds of colors and so that was the
color palette that we went with I think
some people complain because they wanted
to be girlier and some people complain
because they want it to be more gender
neutral but I think you know my my goal
is that you know as long as most girls
are excited about and want to play with
it I think that's great I'm somebody who
personally really likes the color pink
myself so I don't have anything against
it and one thing that's kind of funny
that I've learned is that boys despite
the fact that Goldie Blox has pink in it
couldn't care less and love playing with
it anyway
and they think that this Goldie
character is pretty cool so my view on
the future of gender marketing toward
kids is that I think that those lines
are really blurring and that kids are
kind of no longer like it's it's really
blurring so which is exciting thank you
so much for this
[Applause]
you